Speaker 1: I have video for you today of outrageous
lunatic Pastor Rick Wiles, who says he was
made sick by someone else's vaccine.
This is another guy who claims that there
were people shedding vaccine around him and
it made him sick.
OK, let's take a look at this.
And it's I mean, how does this guy even get
to work in the morning?
Speaker 3: We're witnessing for the first
time in human history, global genocide.
Whoa.
Compliments of the Church of Satan.
The Communist Party is the political arm of
the Church of Satan.
These people that are running the world are
our Satan, us, they're killing off massive
numbers of people.
Speaker 2: Tell me more is doing exactly what
it was created to.
And, you know, this was their plan all along
was to shame the unvaccinated people into
thinking that you're killing these other people.
But really, it's the truth.
It's the vaccinated seem to be carrying whatever
this bio weapon is that they're unleashing
on all of us.
I mean,
Speaker 1: bioweapon,
Speaker 4: what
Speaker 2: went a whole year.
I shook 10000 hands last year on the campaign
trail.
I didn't catch it, didn't catch it all last
year.
Wasn't until people started getting vaccinated.
People start getting really says so.
Speaker 3: And I'm convinced that my infection
and the the explosion that we had here in
our staff, among my family and friends, 20,
some people all together infected suddenly
I believe it came from a vaccinated person
coming into this building who was shedding
the virus.
And I believe that's how it happened.
Speaker 1: That's the culprit, a vaccinated
person.
Now, background on Rick Willes.
This is the guy who once said that the North
Korean threat was caused by gay people.
He said people are going to die because of
gay marriage.
He said that some kind of numerology thing
proves Barack Obama killed Supreme Court Justice
Antonin Scalia.
He said vegan burgers are a satanic plot to
destroy the souls of people.
He said if Trump is removed, there would be
violence.
Well, I mean, listen, Trump lost.
He wasn't removed and there was violence,
but it was the Trump as he warned of a juku
to remove Trump.
And now he says that it was the vaccinated
person, the one vaccinated person that made
everybody sick.
Now, as I've said before, there's no way to
be affected in any way by people around you
being vaccinated with the covid vaccines used
in the United States.
Other than you're less likely to die if people
around you are vaccinated.
If you are sick with covid, your body can
release particles of the virus when you cough,
et cetera.
If you are vaccinated with a vaccine that
contains live virus, there is a short period
of time during which you could be shedding
the virus.
None of the covid vaccines used in the United
States use live virus.
There is no physiological mechanism for that
to happen.
With the covid vaccines in use in the United
States, you can have viral shedding after
a vaccine if it is a live virus vaccine.
The US is not using such vaccines and but
it doesn't matter.
Rick Wiles, is he convinced?
Is he just saying it?
I don't know.
But more dangerous anti vaccine rhetoric.
Is there any good news?
Well, I think the good news is more and more
people have been getting vaccinated for the
last couple of weeks.
The numbers got so low, they are increasing.
That's a good thing.
And let's hope that it continues.
Also, let's hope that The David Pakman Show
continues past our 16th anniversary, the 16th
anniversary coming up on Monday, August 16th.
It's going to be an incredible day, an historic
day.
And we are also deep discounting our website
membership's on that day.
We want to pull in a record number of people.
I think the record for single day new memberships
is something like five.
It's in the five hundreds.
And that happened quite, quite some time ago.
We want to do a single day record for new
members.
You can get on my mailing list at David Pakman
dot com, and then Monday morning you will
be notified.
Remember that the David Pakman show is made
possible primarily by folks like you who get
memberships at Join Pakman Dotcom, I encourage
you to do it.
It just feels good.
I'm told by people you can sign up and use
the coupon code better.
Twenty one if you would like a discount.
No reason that you have to have one, but certainly
welcome to it.